the league of legends summer playoffs
are finally over and we now know what
the groups will look like at worlds 2022
it's exciting stuff and we're gonna get
into it but not without mentioning a
certain pro player first who finally
took home a title after nine years of
trying this one's a tearjerker
[Music]
hey you may have noticed that i'm
wearing some new clothes although it's
kind of difficult to tell behind the
microphone this is actually part of our
brand new merch line that we've recently
brought out it's probably my favorite
t-shirt out of the whole bunch i love
the design we've got loads of cool
designs no i'm not going to say logical
design it sounds [__] lame i buy a
lot of merch i'm a bit of a merch fiend
and honestly i'm not just saying this
this shirt is up there with the most
comfortable i absolutely love it but
don't just take my word for it check it
out for yourself the link to the new
merch shop is in the description box
below check it out all right european
league of legends has a brand new
champion and its name is rogue now rogue
are by no means completely brand new to
the scene after forming in 2019 they've
since represented europe at worlds on
two out of three attempts but one thing
had always evaded them an lec title and
you can't really blame them for the past
few years that had just been handed back
and forth between g2 and mad lions but
after a couple of second and third place
finishes over the last few splits you
got the feeling that roe were picking up
momentum they finished third in the
regular season which earned them a spot
in the upper bracket there they beat mad
lyons before losing to g2 in a clean
sweep and needing to beat fnatic in the
lower bracket finals but finally they
were facing off against g2 once again a
team that had very recently stomped them
3-0 in game one rogue's ad carry comp
show that it doesn't really matter how
you played in the past it's all about
the here and now completely in his comp
comes to take over the fight comes to
kill every single remaining member of g
2 he's
a triple
[Applause]
game two was probably the closest g2
came to knocking down the nexus maorang
salvaged the game by killing g2's wave
and if g2 thought the worst was over
going into game three they were wrong
the final game in the series was a sub
30 minute stomping
in the third game
[Applause]
it was a truly momentous occasion for
rogue they finally succeeded in getting
their first ever title after three years
of some pretty incredible performances
and it's generally momentous for
european league fans too since 2013
top-tier european league has only ever
seen five orgs lift the trophy out of 19
finals perhaps more so than any other
major region this is a land of dynasties
and perhaps this is the start of a new
one but there's someone in this story
that deserves a massive spotlight on
them rogue's long-suffering top laner
odawamne now when i say long-suffering i
don't mean in the sense that all top
laners are suffering on some deep level
although they are i mean in the sense
that odawar nate has been waiting for
glory longer than most people realize
he's been playing league professionally
since early 2013 before many of you guys
watching would have even started playing
his big shot came the following year
with h2k he became one of the most
recognizable names in european league
after helping h2k on an incredible run
to the semi-finals of worlds 2016. but
after leaving h2k the next few years
never saw odawamne reach his previous
heights he struggled with the likes of
splice and shaoka before finding a new
home with rogue at the end of 2020.
after less than half a year of playing
with the team odwamine was able to do
something he hadn't achieved in almost
eight years previously making a european
final when that happened the years of
pent-up emotion finally came out in an
interview crazy is like
it's like
it was such a
such a great ride i guess
um
[Music]
i didn't really you know
expect it tragically for odawame though
rogue fell to mad lyons in a close
best-of-five series odawamnate was quite
literally the last man standing but it
wasn't quite enough the wave's there oh
no i'm nice trying his best he's gonna
fall mad lions are gonna win it is not
rogue it is not fanatic it is not g2 and
the new era of european league of
legends it is the mad lions
and exactly a year on from that they
made it back to the finals only to get
three owed by g2 even if you weren't a
rogue or odawamne fan this was
heartbreaking to see so now you know if
you didn't already know why last
weekend's win really meant so much for
odawamne it was a culmination of almost
a decade of blood sweat and tears and
you could hear every last drop of all
three come through in odawamnee's
post-match interview he really didn't
hold anything back it took a while
a lot of tries and uh
and the reverse sweep as well
a [__] stomp a trio
but now it was our [__] turn to get a
[__] stomp
he finally did it and now oday will head
to worlds 2022 with rogue as europe's
number one seed now i'm sure we'd all
love to see erdogan's fairy tale
continue from here but this might be one
of the toughest years yet for western
fans still if any european or north
american team can put a dent in the
chinese or korean powerhouses there's a
feeling in the air that it might be
rogue they got a pretty favorable
looking group after being handed china's
second seed in top esports and vietnam's
gam esports of course no group at world
is ever easy for western fans but even
after adding in the fourth team that's
yet to come from planes to this group
it's kind of looking like a we take
those situation put it this way at least
they're not cloud9 who have somehow
managed to land a group with last year's
champions in edg and a little-known
squad called t1 with a young lad called
faker in the mid lane a group which
looks suspiciously like the one we had
in 2017. the scriptwriters are really
getting lazy but now isn't the time to
theorycraft the groups at worlds there's
plenty of time in the next few weeks to
do that this is a moment to recognize an
achievement by a man who never gave up
in almost a decade of playing
professionally his story has touched
hundreds of thousands in europe and
around the world there's just so many
cool story lines coming together now for
worlds 2022 throwing erdogan lays in
there just makes it that little bit more
exciting we'll keep you updated
well 90 assignment worlds
well i don't know it's like it's like
being upset if it rains you know there's
no point being upset it's just going to
rain isn't that like
you know it's like it's just it's like
an inevitability really at this point
i feel like next year next year could be
the one cope
what yeah that's right cope